what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so getting into the origin of the first
Lantern ring this is really cool to me
because keep in mind while I have read
Geoff Johns run in preparation for the
videos that we do every Sunday for the
most part I'm only maybe a year removed
if that from light his stories a lot of
people have been reading them for years
like they were reading it when it first
came out and they were following it all
the way along this huge ten-year epic
and so for them like a lot of the stuff
is old hat but for me it's really brand
new in a lot of different ways but the
origin of the first Lantern ring is
actually new material keep in mind while
thoom was a character who appeared in
Geoff Johns Green Lantern run it's just
this guy who was there he was just the
first Lantern the first person to ever
tap into the emotional spectrum we
didn't know his origin we didn't really
know where he hailed from he was just
there one day he was just this prisoner
that the guardians of the universe have
been keeping for quite some time and
then finally he emerged and basically
cut a swath of the entirety of all the
Lantern course so again it was really
cool to see that whole thing unfold but
what DC's done with regards to Green
Lantern's rebirth is remember Green
Lantern's rebirth is basically the new
comic readers guide to the Green Lantern
universe to basically everything that
goes on with the different cores and
different things like that
how Jordan in the Green Lantern Corps is
more for established fans those who have
have basically been reading everything
that Geoff Johns had done and it's a way
to basically reward their loyalty with a
continuation of what they're already
familiar with but for those of you guys
who renew Green Lantern's is really
where you want to start and so because
of this both tombs origin had largely
been fleshed out in DC rebirth and all
we knew was that volthoom was basically
a guy who had hailed from a different
universe this being who is basically
trying to prevent the collapse of the
destruction of his own planet at the
hands of some unknown being you know
some unknown force and the result was
that he and and his mother I believe it
was had basically created something
called the travel Lantern and the travel
Lantern had allowed individuals who were
able to use it to basically traverse one
universe to the next it was literally a
key to access any and all dimensions
that existed in the DC multiverse and so
because of this while volthoom journey
took him to different universes and
those had different results ultimately
he's settled in the main DC Universe and
then ultimately was the person that
allow the guardians to begin tapping
into the emotional spectrum now it
wasn't
the Guardians knew that they were doing
instead it was basically volthoom
showing up and saying hey you guys are
super advanced and super knowledgeable
maybe you can help me find a way to save
my home planet and so the result is that
working alongside the guardians of the
universe the Guardians had had their own
course they had basically come to the
conclusion on their own that emotion was
the biggest cause of all problems that
existed if they were devoid of emotion
they could be pure logical and the
result was that when they cast their
emotions aside when they pulled them all
together it ended up tapping into the
emotional spectrum and spitting out the
first Lantern ring now when it comes to
the emotional spectrum and we've talked
about this before and again bear with me
for those people who are new and haven't
seen this before the idea of the
emotional spectrum is that it's exactly
what it sounds like it's the emotions
that exists within the DC Universe rage
greed fear willpower hope compassion
love death life but remember the arrival
of volthoom and the guardians of the
universe casting their emotions aside
this is basically just two paths that
happen to meet each other and so with
the spewing out of this Lantern ring I
guess this first Lantern ring what it's
done is it's brought the two groups
together because what they know is this
ring basically channels the emotional
spectrum now one thing that I do want to
talk about what you talked about this
once we get towards the end of the video
is the first Lantern ring versus the
white Lantern ring because that's one of
the questions that I get quite a bit and
it's actually a pretty interesting
question it's pretty legit and it really
is an interesting topic to discuss but
the idea here is that because of the
fact that volthoom is very much curious
about the Guardians as they are about
him and the fact that his ring simply
isn't working at the moment the biggest
question the guardians of the universe
have is how does volumes ring work now
keep in mind this also fits very neatly
within the realm of DC's whole you know
guardians of the universe chronology
which is to say that historically
speaking even before geoff johns took
over the green lantern run after the
Guardians had cast aside their emotions
they actually began to shrink in size
down to the beings that were most
commonly familiar with when we think of
guardians of the universe and that's
somebody that like Ramy hits on Rama's
basically this new character who was
introduced as part of DC rebirth this
guy who was basically the smartest of
all the guardians kind of like their
tech guy basically and he's the one that
essentially is trying to work behind the
scenes and figure out how this ring
works directly with volthoom now in
truth this is not really a sanction
Act it's not really something that the
guardians of the universe are okay with
per se it's really just the two of them
working side by side because the other
guardians can't really figure out what's
going on now the other indication here
is that Rama's really the only person
who can actually figure it out because
with him being as smart as he is he
looks around at the other guardians and
says maybe they're just looking at it
all the wrong way and the reason for
this is because Rama's logic dictates
that if the ring was spewed out from the
emotional spectrum then maybe it's not a
matter of like forcing it to work maybe
it's not a matter of technology maybe
it's a matter of emotion and so at that
moment he basically says if it's part of
the emotional spectrum then think of a
moment in your life that made you scared
or made you really angry or whatever the
case may be and in this moment both
foond channels the entirety of the
emotional spectrum now the reason for
this is because of the fact that he's
experiencing a wide array of emotions at
the same time he's afraid that he's
gonna lose the planet that he cares
about he's gonna lose those that are
closer to him because of the fact that
he's afraid of their deaths that means
that he loves them and so there's
compassion there's also the idea that
he's angry at the fact that he feels
helpless in being able to stop it but he
has the will to try to overcome this you
guys see where I'm coming from he's
experiencing the entire emotional
spectrum all at the same time the
problem with this is that being able to
manipulate the entirety of the emotional
spectrum comes with the idea that this
is now unchecked and unrivaled power
within the DC Universe proper now the
other half of this is that because
volthoom is basically using the travel
lantern the logic of Ramy is to say okay
if the travel Antron can be used to
basically jump from one universe to the
other then essentially it's part and
parcel to volthoom himself and so the
result is that the lanterns actually
placed inside of all film it becomes a
physical part of his body structure the
issue with this is that with Ramy using
the travel Lantern to basically look
into the universe that both through
hails from what he ends up finding out
is the destruction of both whose planet
was by both in himself absolute power
corrupts absolutely he had basically
lost his mind he had gone awry with all
the power that he possessed now the
initial attempt by Ramy is to basically
stop this from happening is to stop this
and say hey look you're the reason why
your world ends up getting destroyed you
run you basically get drunk with power
you lose your
mind you basically become this force of
nature now notice as volthoom
is given this information he literally
starts experiencing the emotional
spectrum one Corps at a time so it's why
would you accuse me of such a thing
that's rage he switches to red then it's
well god if I did that then I mean am I
really going to become that person I'm
horrified of the fact that I could
actually do something like that
that's fear now the reason why fear is
so important when it comes to the
emotional spectrum is it's the idea that
it all starts with fear it's the idea
that anybody who basically comes across
a situation that they cannot comprehend
and cannot understand and are terrified
of the consequences that will befall
them because of the situation outside of
their control or at least perceived to
be outside of their control will act out
of fear and this is exactly what happens
with both oonh he literally lashes out
at the guardians of the universe when
they try to strip him of his power when
they try to basically say you cannot use
this you cannot be the person that you
are at the moment you cannot be this
villain we're going to take this travel
lantern away from you we're going to
take this ring away from you if bull
Foom ends up saying no and the response
is that he's just kind of like whatever
I'm gonna go off and do my own thing now
what this does is this leads into the
introduction of the Seven original
lanterns in the sense that with Ramy
realizing devil Foom is basically beyond
control here or at least beyond the
guardians of the universe's ability to
control what he does as he creates seven
Lantern rings seven green lantern rings
and then disperses those Lantern rings
out into the universe basically creating
the original seven green lanterns but
getting into our discussion about this
whole idea of the white Lantern ring
versus the first ring in truth it's not
really a battle of rings per se it's not
really like volthoom is using this ring
to basically do whatever is it he wants
the volthoom is actually mainlining the
emotional spectrum he's using the
entirety of the emotional spectrum at
his disposal and there's a difference
here the white Lantern ring comes when a
person is basically able to master
control and bring together the seven
Lantern cores and what that ended up
doing was creating the white light now
of course that goes into you know the
aftermath of blackest night going into
brightest day so on and so forth but
when it comes to to a white Lantern it's
really them just using the entirety of
the Rings as opposed to mainlining the
emotional spectrum and so in this
instance it's really like volthoom I
would argue
would probably come out on top here he's
not using a battery you know he's not
using an electrical outlet like he is
the electricity you know he's basically
the source of energy he is the emotional
spectrum in a lot of ways because
instead of you know going through this
and then to that and then through that
and getting to the emotional spectrum
he's just going directly to the source I
don't know if that really makes a whole
lot of sense hopefully it does but
that's essentially the difference here
there's Kyle Rayner is or I guess as the
white lantern is using the 7 Lantern
rings together as one cohesive unit and
creating a white Lantern ring with both
ooh it's not even going to that step
instead it's just using the entirety of
the emotional spectrum so again it's
basically you know using the source
itself as opposed to what the source
could possibly create kind of one of
those weird ambiguous things hopefully
that made sense but it's a pretty cool
story because again this goes on to the
whole exploration of the Green Lantern's
this goes on to the whole exploration of
you know what's going on with these
origin stories how it all ties together
and all that kind of good stuff but if
you guys are new here to comics explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]